and
[Silence]
We are continuing
in as an extension
of as we've mentioned
before
discussing The Life and Times of the
Prophet Muhammad s. wasallam
we are reading out of the
book we discussed
previously the chapter regarding the
prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam and his physical
characteristics we then discussed his
character and now we are discussing his
miracles all of the Miracles not all of
them but
many of the most prominent and
well-known miracles of the prophet
sallallahu wasam he himself was
considered a miracle Allah subhanahu wa
taala mentions the prophet Sall alam's
Miracle along with the miracle of the
Quran often in the Quran he will mention
the quran's miraculous nature he will
mention the prophet Muhammad s alai
wasallam as a miracle as well a miracle
in what sense a miracle in the sense of
his obedience to Allah subhanahu
waala his steadfastness his generosity
Etc we see that he is mum and all of the
prophets and messengers of Allah are
considered as miracles of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala they're not people
who
fall short with with the rights of
Allah subhanahu waala there are people
that are kept steadfast by Allah
subhanahu wa taala throughout the
entirety of their prophethood until they
return to he
subhah
[Silence]
we discussed and spoke
about Malik on numerous occasions
Malik met the prophet s. wasam in his
early days in Mecca as well in his
migration from Mecca to
Medina there was a bounty out we we
mentioned his story qur had placed a
bounty on the prophet sallallah alai
wasam and Abu bak and anyone
accompanying him that whoever captured
Capt captures them will receive a
generous and
handsome reward and
so Malik attempted to capture the
prophet Sall wasam when he was spotted
in route from Mecca to Medina he was
unable to do so the prophet
s gave him the option to become
Muslim he turned that
invitation down but he
[Silence]
said
was invited by the prophet
s to Islam he turned that invitation
down but he made he came to an
agreement he
said I will never fight against you nor
will I ever be with a people that fight
against you this is what he promised him
the prophet Salli wasam let him go based
on that but
Malik wanted
safety in
return he wanted to be
guaranteed that when the prophet sallai
wasam becomes dominant in the Arab
peninsula
that Malik will be in
safety because the things that Surak
saw when and he was as is
in as he was
attacking the prophet sallallah alai
wasallam trying to chase them down with
his horse and his
spear he heard the prophet
sallam making Dua as he drew near to
him and suddenly the two the front legs
of the horse were sucked into the ground
they sank into the ground and the horse
bucked him
off he got on it again and attempted
again
to attack the prophet sallallah alai
wasallam to capture him and again in a
different place his horses front legs
were sunk into the ground and he was
bucked off and he realized that this is
this is not a
this is not a coincidence this is not
a natural natural phenomenon this is a
prophet he really is a
messenger and being that that is the
case no matter what it looks I'm
never going to be able to capture him
it's just not going to
happen and if he is a
prophet then he will eventually become
dominant in the
region Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has
promised him victory over his enemies
and he has promised that Islam and his
religion his sh will
be dominant in the region in the
world and
soik he said I do not accept Islam
however I promise that I will not fight
against you or be with anyone who fights
against you with any people who fight
against
you and then the prophet sallai wasam
promised him safety
but Sak wanted more he said he wants it
written down for him he wanted it
written
abak was literate and so he had Abu Bakr
write for
him
a message or a letter of safety granting
him safety that in the future if any of
the military of the Prophet sallallah
alai wasam or any of the Muslims come
across him he will show them that he has
this Refuge from the
prophet exempting
him and
so who took that and fast forward to
the conquest of Mecca the prophet.
wasallam came into
Mecca and Mecca was then
conquered and considered a Muslim
territory a Muslim City at that point
and came to the Companions and showed
them his letter of Refuge that he was
given by the prophet sallallah alai
wasam years prior he gave him this and
they took him to the prophet sallallah
wasallam and he accepted Islam on in the
conquest of me on the day of that's when
he became
Muslim
now Malik when he became Muslim the
prophet s. wasam gave him Glad Tidings
that one day he said to he said one day
you are going to wear the bracelets of
kisra who is the Persian
Emperor bracelets and also the folk
which is kind
of
basically it's jewelry right but it's
it's for the king so he would have these
bracelets that he would wear that are
adorned and also a kind of necklace
or a kind of thing that would be fixed
around his neck and he informed K that
he will one day wear those pieces of
jewelry now of course you got to
understand the context
here this is almost
unimaginable I mean we understand that
the prophet
s conquered Mecca was a big difference
between the conquest of the city of
Mecca with Arab tribes ununited and the
Empire of the Persians big difference
between the two I mean just a few years
prior the prophet and his companions
were having difficulty with the other
Tri tribes of the Arab
peninsula but he told him this and this
occurred in the time
of the narration is mentioned
in authored
by also mentions this narration in which
is not an original reference of Hadith
but it is
nonetheless one of the places that
this is
mentioned that the prophet sallallah
alai wasallam made him this promise and
that this promise and this prophecy came
to pass in the conquest of me in in the
time of
Omar in the successorship of
Omar and
so
when kisra
fell and when the Persian Empire was
conquered by the Muslims in the time of
Omar
The Treasure of KRA was brought to
Medina Medina was the capital of the
Muslim
empire and Omar was
there for these Treasures to be
dispersed and distributed amongst the
Muslims
and in these
Treasures the his General brought him
the
bracelets and the chain or necklace
of and
so
called for
Malik and when
Malik came he put these on him he put
these bracelets on him and he paraded
him around in the streets of
Medina saying
alhamdulillah that Allah
subhanahu has dressed the
follower of Muhammad s. wasam with the
jewelry of kingship of kisra and this
was in the streets of Medina so this
prophecy came to pass within 20 years of
it being
prophesized he
[Silence]
says
AB
[Silence]
abif
m
[Silence]
for
another prophecy that the prophet
s
prophesized was that alassan IB Ali his
grandson his eldest
grandson
would be
instrumental in
uniting the Muslims in a time of
division and in summary the story of
this is that he made this prophecy when
he was when alassan was a
child and he said this about him the
narration is in as we mentioned he told
his companions and he took up alassan on
the MIM while he was giving and he said
to the companions this son of
mine grandson is
a a
noble
individual and Allah will use him and he
will be
instrumental in uniting the Muslims in a
time of division after my
passing and so fast forward to the
murder
of the third Khalifa of the Prophet
sallallah alai wasallam his third
successor and his son-in-law of two of
his daughters
due to some rumors that were floating
around and some issues some people from
Egypt and elsewhere none of them
companions none of them
companions these are mistakes made in
some of the books that float around that
people read they get
misinformation no companions were
involved in the murder
of ever
no one who met the prophet Muhammad s.
wasam ever was involved in the murder
of however he was
basically imprisoned confined to his
home and eventually he was murdered in
his
home when this happened the companions
had two opinions on how to deal with
this
situation it's not enough just to take
the people who
killed man the individuals right there's
about five individuals this is not
enough because these individuals killed
o Man based on what a political
agenda and
so these individuals are representative
and representing those who stand behind
them in this
fitna so this was an issue that later de
developed and
evolved into the movement of
theage who later came
to judge
Ali to judge him as an apostate they
thought he they said he left Islam he
was no longer a Muslim Muslim because of
some differences that they had with
him this
FNA was just starting out and just
really starting
to sprout in the time
ofan it later escalated to his
murder when this happened the companions
were of two opinions with regards to
this murder now we have to understand
the entire Muslim was United
underman butman had major governors in
the different lands different
parts one of those parts was AEM which
is Damascus
deash and there deash was under the
governance of
mu he's a companion and his father was a
companion is a
very
controversial figure in Islamic
history amongst many groups of
innovation that came out
muan because of the differences that
occurred between he and and
because of these differences each one
of them had a group or a nation of
people that bolstered them and so of all
the
companions of all of the
companions the companion who has the
most fabricated narrations about him
is and
mu why because the people that were
behind muaah the ignorant of them would
fabricate narrations to bolster their
position and in turn dis
praise and they would also fabricate
narrations claiming that the prophet s.
wasam praised muaah in ways that he did
not that is not
authentic the same is true for the
followers
of either fabricated
narration about Al some of them to the
point of almost making him a prophet or
a
messenger and other Fabrications dis
praising him or dis praising MUA
most of those narrations are inauthentic
they're lies they were politically
driven
lies and what better evidence for
you for you to have than the prophet
[Arabic recitation]
agreeing with you that's the that's the
mentality
right and
so a difference of opinion occurred
between
and many people are under
the
they are under the false
impression
that had his falling out
with over the successorship over the
that is not true mu never asked for the
the issue was that
was
murdered wanted to make sure that the
Muslims be completely United meaning the
people of Hashem right and how is that
well when a new Khalifa would be
appointed the governors from all of
those different lands aam and Yemen and
all the different you know states of
the Muslim empire at the time
those governors would publicly give and
pledge their allegiance to the new
Khalifa right and so the people that
they stand for are behind them as
well and that unites all of the Muslims
under one successor under one Khalifa
and that's very
important because when a Khalifa
dies or in this casean was murdered
right any any person of
authority when that person passes
away we have what we have a power vacuum
that happens anybody who has any good or
bad intentions will utilize that
Discord in order to fulfill their own
political agenda whatever it is so it is
absolutely
crucial that when that power vacuum
comes up that it be closed as soon as
possible by appointing a leader a
unified
leader for all of the Muslims so that
that is a door
closed this happened even and especially
we could say with the death of the
Prophet sallai
wasam when he passed
away the first thing that the companions
did before they buried
him was to give allegiance to
abak and all of the tribes and all of
the Muslims agreed and gave pledge their
allegiance to the new
abak before he was even buried yet right
why is that because the prophet
sallallah alam's body is preserved by
Allah prophets do not suffer
from Decay their body
their bodies are preserved by Allah
subhah waala as the prophet himself
tells
us that's not an issue the
issue is that power vacuum being left
open and drawing in unsavory characters
who will capitalize on the Discord and
the
division and
so this same thing happened with
and mu said look I have no
problem pledging allegiance to you
giving you my allegiance the allegiance
of the people of Hashem who I stand for
and as their
governor
however before I do that I demand that
the killers of Earth man be brought to
Justice now publicly now once that
happens I give you the
allegiance the problem is is that the F
the people who stood Behind The Killers
ofman those
individuals are part of a bigger
group later
became and many different groups of and
factions these
groups made up a huge portion of the
Muslim Army in Iraq at the time
and we're talking about in the thousands
some estimates plac them at about 6,000
soldiers who were upon this misguidance
this innovation
of right and so in order for him
to put all of these people into check
and this entire group if he were to do
that now to bring these killers to
Justice and it's a religious thing with
these other group this could cause a war
between his army there could be a mutiny
in his own Army but the idea
was we pl you you give me the allegiance
and then we can take care of that
situation but before that I need the
authority to be able to do that and that
Authority comes by way of unifying the
Muslims was fixated on that opinion he
felt that that's that's what should
happen because he was afraid if that
didn't happen it wouldn't happen if it
didn't happen before he pledged
Allegiance so he was using it as
leverage to get Justice
for this a different way of looking at
the same issue they both agree on the
essential part of it what is it that the
killers ofan have to be brought to
justice that they that
Ali should be made Theif of the
Muslim they all agreed on that that's
not an issue of contention the
contention was
a is it politic is it prudent to
bring these killers to Justice now or
wait until we consolidate power to do so
consolidate all of the
Muslim Muslims power to do this this is
where the the point of contention
happened and
so the had moved the capital of the
Muslim empire had moved to irq at that
time and
mu was in a sham in
deash and friction happened between them
right this was in the lifetime of the
companions many of the companions were
still alive most of them
and most of the
companions refus to in you know get
involved only about 30 some
companions all the books of History were
recorded to have been involved in this
situation that happened
between
mu both of them are
companions both of them are
Companions of the Prophet Muhammad s.
wasam both of them were Muslim both of
them were fighting for the same
essential cause it's just the way of
attaining that cause was the difference
in the point of
contention so of course whenever there's
two groups that are at odds with each
other rumors start to crop up on both
sides the zealots and there are zealots
in every group
right the zealots of th that group they
are going to be extreme in their
dispraise of the opposition and extreme
in their Praise of them themselves right
that's how humans are human beings are
rarely ever moderate in anything
humans we are very extreme in the things
that we do and the things that we
want and so because of this there are
many narrations
praising in a way that is beyond him
just being a companion or the praise
that he legitimately has and then there
are other narrations extreme in the
dispraise of mu and this happened even
between
the right even between the the
zets of the
Hani the of
Abu
and the zealots of the
Sha and those two and before that it was
the Maliki and the
Hani they were viewed as being two
essentially
different one was based strictly on
tradition the other based a lot on
opinion and the word opinion is is a
broad word that that means a lot of
different things that we won't get into
but then we have narrations
they're not their Fabrications their
their lies the prophet sallallahu alaih
wasallam never said them but they were
nonetheless recorded by the scholars of
Hadith as
Fabrications and that is you'll for
instance you may find a narration and
this is a real
narration
[Silence]
right
s
so we see narrations that start to crop
up because of that
conflict so for instance in the books of
Hadith it's a fabricate these are
fabricated narrations these are not real
narrations right but they're
Fabrications someone somewhere along the
line
claimed that the prophet Muhammad
Sall said this these are not real
narrations one narration
States claiming that the prophet Sall Al
wasam said a man will come at the end of
time or near the end of time who is more
dangerous upon my nation my umah than
theel himself than the Antichrist
himself his name is
Muhammad there's a narration is that an
authentic narration obviously not there
a why but where does a narration like
that come from because even lies have
Origins right this narration comes from
the zealots the ignorant zealots of the
Hani mhab who are at odds with the shaf
you have other
narrations such as my nation will always
be rightly guided as long as they follow
Abu
hanifa this a real narration obviously
not this is a fabrication according to
all of the scholars of Hadith where does
a lie that come from who fabricates
such lies obviously the zealots of the
Hani and there
are there is the contrary in the in the
shaf and the Maliki and all the MB that
are at odds with each other those who
claim to be followers of that MB they
become extreme and they start to make
things up whether it's lies about the
other or Li
that they ascribed to the prophet
sallam Etc the same thing happened with
the friction and the conflict that took
place between mu
Andi there were a couple of
battles however essentially they came to
a
truce and
mu had yet
to pledge his Allegiance and the
allegiance of the people of
aam to
Ali both governing bodies
continued in relative
Harmony
until was murdered he was killed by the
same group that began and the same group
that
murdered he was killed by
abdb MIM and ABD rman
MJ was a reciter of the
Quran had appointed him to teach Quran
in his
time and he got sucked into the
basically the cult of
the and he took it upon himself to
wait the coward he was in the dark
just before F
when was on his way to wake people up in
on his way to the Masjid and he came out
and he attacked him
and
subsequently succumbed to his
injuries about three days
after now when this happened remember
what we said about Authority and power
vacuums when
Ali was who was viewed by the majority
of the Muslims as being the the Khalifa
of the Prophet sallallah alai wasam and
the unified head of the Muslim empire
when he passed away we have that power
vacuum again and the further we get away
from the time of the Prophet sallai
wasallam the more dangerous something
that
becomes and so immediately
the
companions who was left of them and the
Muslims
and they all
unanimously pledged allegiance to his
son the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam grandson but muaah still had
the same issue that he had before and so
alassan after about six
months he
seceded to muaah so he he he relented
if you
will he relinquished his authority as
the Khalifa and he pledged Allegiance
with all of the rest of the Muslims
behind him to
Mu when that happened the umah was made
whole again and everyone was United once
again this is the prophecy the
Fulfillment of the
prophecy that we just mentioned and that
is that the prophet
Sall said about alassan when he was a
little boy to the companions on the
mimber he picked him up on the MIM and
he showed him to the Companions and he
said this son of mine is one of nobility
and Allah subhanahu wa taala is going to
unite you use him and he will be
instrumental in uniting my nation in a
time of division and that was the
Fulfillment of that
prophecy you know more than 35 or so
years
[Silence]
later